this this this guy does not represent
Christianity at all yeah firstly I want
to say that from the GetGo because these
question in was to Expos yeah so so
there's many Christians that are that
are well versed in what we're talking
about and they're able to address these
things and have these conversations and
go and go to some some depth okay
unfortunately this guy he just you can
see he's got an agenda um he just wants
to kind of shout over people and and and
speak the idea about chain of
transmission he said Christians were the
ones that gave it to him that that
doesn't help us with is again imagine if
we took a Hadith and we say this Hadith
has been narrated by Muslims and that's
our only criteria is that it was
narrated by Muslims this is not this is
not acceptable the Muslims have to show
their chain of narration their
transmission we mentioned there was five
before this the side recording we
mentioned there were five conditions for
authentic Hadith uh one of them is
precision one of them is upright in
character connection of chain uh uh not
not um not contradiction that which is
stronger than it than than not
contradicting that which is stronger
than it and other conditions as well
yeah
so and no defect no yeah of course
exactly exactly no hidden defect exactly
so we mentioned this and we said this is
what we would need in order for someone
to say this Hadith is and we can accept
this Hadith that's the first
in terms of the and the understanding of
the again there's still there's still a
layer of scholarship that we have to go
through how do you understand these
things there still there still that kind
of level now for him he can attack us
and say you take from your uncles and
this one and your grandads and whatever
no we don't that's we wouldn't accept
that thei would
be if someone is unknown person we
cannot accept ite sh again okay um so
this is the thing so again he mentioned
we have eyewitnesses Matthew is not an
eyewitness the one who wrote this this
an assumption they have that the author
of Matthew is Matthew the author of John
is John the author of Luke is Luke the
author of Mark is these are an
assumptions we need to test them first
Matthew is written in highly polished
Quin Greek as many non-muslim scholars
would attest to that this is like a high
level of uh Greek language so Matthew
was a tax collector yes he would have
known some Greek yes he would have known
uh some of the language of the Romans
that he's that he's collecting taxes for
but would he be highly polished no it
doesn't necessitate that if he was
demonstrate it that's an assumption okay
so Matthew we can assume he's not an
it's unlikely that he's an eyewitness
okay and the Matthew that we have was
not written in Hebrew we know the early
church fathers they mentioned and they
made mention of a of of a Matthew the
disciple who wrote a gospel in Hebrew
known as The Gospel to the Hebrews okay
which is which is coincidental as well
because we know that in the time in in
in uh in Mecca he would write the Gospel
in Hebrew so it wasn't a Greek gospel
the layer before these ones that we have
now these gospels that we have it was
the original teachings of Jesus what was
jesus' primary audience they were Hebrew
speaking Aramaic speaking According to
some opinions um so we want to know that
layer before Greek cuz we know as we
know as well that the translator is from
the isnad so if you if you know if you
don't know the translator the translator
is transmitting information to you and
he's also trying his best to put it from
one one language to another he is from
the chain of transmission the trans the
translator is from the isnad so if you
don't know who wrote The Greek then how
can you say how can you say that we have
uh we have eyewitnesses and you have
your uncles and your aunties that you're
taking from you know that mention you
explain which
one to read at the end so at the end of
John it says now now this is the
disciple who who wrote these things I'm
paraphrasing but you can check it John
21 this is a disciple who wrote these
things and we testify that his testimony
is true so what is what is talking
somebody I the Ora is speaking in the
first person plural so we so he's saying
we we testify we bear witness that what
he has said is true so okay that sounds
good but who's the we if someone comes
now and says I uh I've got a a Brank
manuscript here and it says we testify
that Jesus said that John said that
Jesus said x y and Zed we're not going
to how can you accept it because you
don't know who is the wi who is giving
you the transmission so this is why and
and why John is so um important is
because John has the highest christology
Mark has a lower christology very human
this is the earliest gospel Jesus is
very human Matthew and Luke is kind of
elevated but it's still soptic is still
in the same view John is highly highly
kind of spiced up a highly exalted view
of of Jesus if you look in the previous
uh the synoptic gospels Mark uh Matthew
and Luke you'll see that Jesus if you
look when when did he uh when was he
become Son of God uh was it was it on
the day of the baptism was it when he
was crucified look at John John he was
there before Abraham was I am he's
always been there so the elevation of
Jesus's status is is is primarily in
John outside the churches when you want
to see the the big quotes is um I am the
way the truth and the life when you ask
a Christian where where does it say that
Jesus said he was God ah before Abraham
was I am I am the way and the truth the
life um all the great am statements it's
well known okay so that's the source of
the high christology not to say that
Mark is is a Muslim gospel or Matthew
and but we can see elevation the later
on you go the higher the christology the
further back you go the lower the
christology now if you go before Mark
which is before all of the the the
gospels Mark is the First Gospel written
that they they have if you go before
that what you would see is that you find
a a Jesus that is exactly the same as
the Jesus of the Quran and this is what
historians are saying and there's a
there's a a book called James and the
James and the church or James the
brother of Jesus by Jeffrey buts amazing
book he highlights this point he's he's
from I think he's from Michigan
University of Michigan he highlights
this point and he shows that uh the the
the key to understanding the true Jesus
from a historical point of view is James
and when you see that James who prayed
in the temple who told him to worship
the god of Israel who viewed the only
difference he he differed with the Jews
is viewing that Jesus was the Messiah
this is how we differed with the Jews
now this James and this historical Jesus
Jeffrey buts mentions that it it lines
up exactly with the Muslim Jesus and we
can see this we can see that when we we
understand these things and we take away
the layers that's been added on from
these unknown scribes and unknown
sources you can see that a pure Islamic
Jesus who prayed to God they can even
see in their own text there's still
remnants in there for them to see the
Lord's Prayer our father is who are in
heaven Hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will be done on Earth as it is
in heaven give us this day our daily
bread and forgive us our trespasses as
we forgive those who trespass against us
what's apart from the word Father which
we have some issues later on now with
Islam the word father we have there's
some issues with that apart from that if
you understand that Jesus is telling the
disciples to pray to his Lord he tell
them to pray to the father this is this
is they still have it in John as well
this is true life that they may know you
the only true father so the clear and
ambiguous statements are there to show
that Jesus prayed to God he got he has a
God he taught others to pray to God he
told others to to to submit and humble
themselves to this God and that that you
would have faith if you humble whoever
humbles himself will be made highest and
whoever makes himself high will be
humbled so this is this is what this is
what the the teaching of Jesus was okay
now we have these people and they just
you can see you can see alhamdulillah so
again this is why when the prophet
Muhammed PE upon Him Not only was he
prophesized in their scripture he's
expected why would he expect why is why
do we say it's expected because if their
book has been corrupted unknown unknown
offers manuscripts differ with each
other um people just fabricate in the
name in the name of Jesus we have these
things um uh it's only right that God
would send a prophet afterwards to
clarify so not only is he prophesying is
in this in their Bible many times he's
also expected there needs to be another
Prophet because this scripture is
corrupted so Allah has sent his last
prophet Muhammad wasallam to clarify for
these things just to mention some of the
prophecies that are maybe not as well
known our Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him um uh uh the companions came to him
and they said we know how to send Salam
upon you but how do we send Salat upon
you taught them uh the the we say in the
then he also
said we find in Genesis in chapter 12 it
says a promise to Abraham we know the
promise to to is that is that Allah will
make him a great nation the what the
Christians all of them are aware of the
pro the promise to Isaac and the Jews
are aware the promise to Isaac they
highlight on that one that the Covenant
will be with him there's also uh a uh
what we believe the Covenant was taken
but there's also a covenant and a
blessing for ibraim and that is I will
bless those who bless you so daily every
day the Muslims we and and and you and
it says I will bless those who bless you
and your name will be used as a blessing
okay never in history do we have as many
people today sending um uh blessing upon
ibraim and using his name to send
Blessing on others
like as we do today with the Advent of
um he mentions
in his his book of Quran he mentions
regarding the of
the he mentions in the of that that this
affirmation this T that we do this T
that we do is an it's a reaffirmation of
the original blessing upon ibraim so we
bless ibraim
daily we say this daily okay and we do
it in our t
and we use his name as a blessing but
this has never happened with anybody
other than the Advent ofam and Allah
mentioned that he would do that he would
make his name a blessing why because
ibraim left his land he made hij from
the land of the mus when you make Hijra
from somebody your name becomes unknown
your lineage becomes unknown but whether
and and your wealth uh becomes uh uh
diminished but what did Allah do and
Allah has promised this for others that
make Hijra uh that Allah has blessed him
increased him in wealth Allah increased
ibraim in wealth Allah increased his
name so much so that we said that we are
upon the Miller of ibraim is not anybody
else the of IIM specifically and then he
also expanded his
lineage Al that's just one prophecy
alhamdulillah we we have the Allah the
father oh okay okay so so so um from
from Islam from from the the teachings
of Islam is that when we call uh Allah a
name or an attribute that there are
certain principles that that um that um
that we we have to take into
consideration with regards to that we
don't call Allah by any name that he
hasn't called
himself in the Quran or in the Quran or
in the sunah of his messenger it's
possible that in a different Sharia that
he has different names that that he's
kept with himself s or revealed to a
different uh Prophet at a different time
that's why have the famous Dua ofam
where he ask oh Allah I ask you by every
name that you have given yourself or Tau
any one of the creation so there are
other names that Allah and there are all
that you have kept a name by yourself in
the in the Unseen so uh we don't say
that father was not a name of Allah but
we don't say it was a name of Allah now
the problem that comes with the word
father is the connotations that we see
with the Christians with father comes
son and this is the this is now the
Trinity the whole idea of uh the son
being part of the Father the same
attributes and so on and so forth this
whole confusion that we see the the the
this is the thing that makes people
shout and scream this thing so confusing
you have no clear answer you have to
shout and scream so this is the this is
the conclusion of having a confusion a
belief that is confusing in their
scripture it says God is not the author
of confusion and when it mentioned when
when we mention this to them they become
irate and you can see What's happen we
tried to be reasonable obviously we're
we're going to be firm as well sometimes
we tried to be reasonable we try to
understand but there's certain limit you
got you got to take I could have walked
away there he would have ran after me
and said ah you ran away you got to
understand if a man doesn't want to
speak to you because you'll being like
that fair
enough never never answered it and then
what's what's crazy even T mentions this
that whenever they attack Islam they
fall into the same thing he attacked
Islam for taking from uncles and aunties
and unknowns when I asked him who he
said Christians when I asked him who he
said ah the the Christians said it and
and it's all in there no reference we
mentioned names for example IM in M of
IM Malik before before bukari he said
bukari came L 200 the M IM Malik imik
took from took from took from directly
we have don't don't even try it with us
when it comes to this we boast about
this mentioned um that Allah he
specified this religion with three
things that he hasn't specified with any
other religion knowledge of the Arabic
language know knowledge of the lineage
and knowledge of the isnad and this is
this is we can see it today when we have
these discussions he becomes angry when
we ask him for his isad he said we don't
even need isad
Allah